so musics been quite a big part of my
life as a PhD and kind of my life in
general recently so I thought I dedicate
this whole minisode talking about it
whilst kind of the rest of my life
happens if this stuff doesn't interest
you then come back next minisode and
there'll be something different the
reason I bring this up today is because
today we have our second equal time so
I'm in the music practice rooms here in
call my house to a little bit of a lunch
time but I thought whilst I'm here I
could talk about my musical journey I
guess
so I was with a lot of people I guess my
musicality largely comes from my parents
though interestingly I think to be the
middle of two because my mum is a singer
she's an opera singer amateur and it's
phenomenally musical and she actually
plays saxophone now as well
by contrast my dad was asked to stop his
piano lessons by his piano teacher so
yeah I'm kind of somewhere in between
the two so I wanted to tell the story in
a more interesting way than just meet
sit down for you know have many minutes
and talk the entire time so we'll be
popping back to call more help to hear
the next chapter every thought now I
need to crush a bug that I've identified
like a code entomologist not our code
etymologist though that would be pretty
cool actually
now for the longest time I wasn't
musical at all I didn't exactly show
much promise my mum with my mum would
take stickers and put them on the piano
that we have at home for her practicing
with like cdef written on them but I
don't think I showed much much promise
and I just made basically the words of
my mum I wasn't very disciplined and I
didn't I just didn't have the right
mindset for it at all so for quite a
long time I was not musical in any way
so I identified this problem earlier
which I partially fixed well rather I
have now corrected what the problem was
but I think it's causing problems
further down the line this is very vague
I'm going to say the scintillating
discussion that's the distinction
between geopotential what it's relevant
to for tomorrow because you know can't
put all the quality stuff in too soon
suffice to say one set of problems would
that occurs in a place with another set
but I think them well they're certainly
easy to understand not as wow that's
bright
hello but I think they'll be easier to
fix so you know that's a job for
tomorrow Simon
so now Simon I've got a decent singing
I love it and I love it I absolutely
love it now this isn't to say that I
wasn't interested in music because I was
I was exposed to a lot of music nails
kids when we were in the car we had
tapes tapes by the way for young people
are like see now gods didn't have CDs
anymore
they're like mini phones or iPods but
they only played like eight songs and
you can rewrite them well some of them
you could see if we had these tapes in
the car and in particular I remember
listening to a lot of meatloaf
distearate The Beatles I had my own copy
of sergeant pepper's Lonely Hearts Club
Band so basically not a huge amount of
classical influence for quite a long
time
yeah I didn't exactly given with mum
being an opera singer I went to some
other rehearsals but I didn't exactly
grow at classical music
[Music]
so often in music you find notes in
previous college I think this might be
my favorite one I've ever found
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so we've done some pretty banging
services in our time but that might well
be the best service we ever sung music
was tough like really difficult music
but I'm we mean out it considering that
music it also wasn't too long because
the anthem was 15 minutes long which
normally means that the service is over
an hour but kept Thresh basically said
we could go home now you're trying to
give me a heart attack today my first
exposure to classical music was playing
the corner I basically I heard them a
bugler playing the last post on TV and I
was like I want to do that and so I had
a couple of years of lessons playing a
corner corner for the it's not like an
ice-cream thing in a mini trumpet and I
could probably still play one I can
still do brass nut pieces they're all
basically the same but I haven't played
for over a decade the real breakthrough
came when I started playing saxophone
which was different honest instrument I
would have wanted to started playing but
I was a bit intimidated by the number of
keys because there are so many on a
saxophone and there are only three on a
corner and I was like yeah I'm going to
go for the easier thing
so amazing to come out a chapel that
it'd be gorgeous like super super green
and sunny like this in the winter you
get used to coming out of services and
it's really dark but this is so nice
I mean come on this is obscene the photo
Mediterranean because of my it's so nice
this evening that I'd love to go for a
run but I feel like three runs in three
days as a little bit excessive so I'm
going to go for another swim yeah when I
started playing saxophone I start off a
lot of jazz but actually one of the
pieces that I really got attached to you
was the cello suites by buck and there's
a transcription for saxophone and I've
been I was studied them several years
and like tries to get my skill up where
I could play them maybe someday I could
do that on each you but yeah and I
played saxophone in school and with
lessons and in wind bands for write the
way up until I left school and then when
I went Oxford Paul was but by the
swimming club I can't go in see my Z
name it painting suggest I said I and my
breakfast cupcake and I I was actually
exhausted and I was like you know what
like I'll do it now
and like this will be the work are so
nice
[Music]
so at Oxford I continued to play
saxophone in a nun edition twin band
which was needed I think it was Oxford I
realized just how important music was to
me because for the first year I didn't
play and I realized just how much I
missed it you know even just playing 2
hours a week it really becomes quite low
level stuff was so beneficial to my
mental health you know Kate kind of kept
me on my last sliver of sanity through
Oxford but I didn't do anything other
than that I didn't do for example do any
singing oh it's done this thing again oh
yeah so this camera took a little bit of
a tumble earlier
yeah it slightly fell off I'll totally a
face don't worry so they can't see you
smiling so because the pool is closed
and we didn't feel like going for
another run I feel like I like you oh I
cut you really nice dinner on a scale of
1 to piss how good was it yes you use
piss all the time
yeah no I said piss Oh
[Music]
so the majority of the musical life
you've seen me engaged with in these
vlogs it's stuff like this it's it's
shuffle evensong and Eucharist and stuff
done with Chapel Choir but I didn't sing
until I came to exeter as a matter of
fact the only reason I'm singing at all
is because I went to an audition to
impress a girl which works I'd like to
point out and because the person in that
audition liked my voice even though it
had no training today I still haven't
had a single singing lesson in my life
they liked my voice and thought that I
kids pick up slightly and quickly enough
that certainly gave me a place in their
choir and then because of that audition
I than have another audition and then
because of that audition I was then
offered a place in Chapel Choir which is
where I've been since so literally the
whole reason that I do this stuff
week in week out now is because I wanted
to impress a girl and I got in a little
bit too deep
[Music]
[Laughter]
and that basically leads up the present
day I'm a choral scholar so again I
should get paid to sing and I was the
vice president the a cappella Society on
campus until the great a cappella war of
2014 and I loved it I absolutely loved
it and in a way I'm annoyed at myself
for not having started music and singing
in particular earlier it has been the
best way to make friends the friends
I've made free Chapel Choir have been
the closest friends I've made in Exeter
and some of our closest friends in my
life because there's something unique
about going through a performance
together and particularly about singing
because there's nothing between you and
the music there's no instrument there's
just you are the instrument the air is
your tool and so when you have a group
of people who come together and bring
music to life that was written down
hundreds of years ago to elicit the same
emotional response through your unity
your controller beg for your bodies
basically to elicit that same response
as was intended 400 years ago
camera spoiling is amazing now I
actually need to get on with practicing
because I talked for ages but I really
like to learn if you're musical because
I think a lot of people in the comments
I've seen before have been musical and
in particular a lot of things so down
there if you've got an interesting
musical story um but you know how you've
gotten to where you are because I think
I've shown that there's no one set path
to musicianship I certainly was a
musician for all my life I still
struggle to call myself a musician now
to be honest I always think it's
interesting to other people's versions
so do you comment if you if you've got
your musical story and where you started
where you are now and maybe if you're
thinking about doing in the future what
you'd like to do I know it can come off
as kind of facetious to feign interest a
new audience which enemy I'm really
interested my favorite part of being a
youtuber is the interactions with you
guys and learning about your lives so
you know I talk about me for long enough
I want to hear about you so while I get
back to this comment down that
[Music]
Oh